The next time you're at a wedding, I
want you to keep track of how many
speakers start their speeches like this.
Hello? Whoa, this microphone's loud.
For those who don't know me,
my name is Wade and I'm the best man.
I will bet you at least one speaker
starts their speech that way
and it's a weak opening.
It's a missed opportunity because the
reality is there's probably an MC at
that wedding who has already introduced
you as the best man.
There were probably agendas or programs
on the different table that have your
name and explain that you are best man.
Yet so often speakers feel the need to
explain who they are, why they're there,
when instead
something like this could work much
better.
Today,
I am Jeremy's best man.
But in fifth grade,
we were arch enemies.
All right.
Now the audience, the guests of the
wedding are thinking there's a story
here.
This is This is interesting. I thought
Wade and Jeremy were always best
friends. What happened in fifth grade?
We've hooked their attention. Don't fall
into the same patterns many amateur
speakers make of the formalities.
Instead, disrupt those patterns. Share a
story. Give a surprising fact. Ask a
thought-provoking question. These are
the ways to capture an audience's
attention when you give a speech. In
this video, I am going to break down all
sorts of weak speech openings and then
showcase alternative examples of what
could work well.
Before I get into those examples, if you
are somebody who is a business leader or
an executive or somebody who really
wants to take public speaking seriously,
check out my stand store link below in
the video description because I have
several options such as private
one-on-one lessons working with you. I
want you to be a more confident
communicator
and to help you in your career because
public speaking is one of the most
important leadership skills there is.
So, if that is you, you're a leader or
an executive or a professional, check
out that link. All right, back to the
examples. Have you ever been at an event
where the speaker comes up to the front
of the room or stands on stage and opens
with something like this.
Hey everyone. Um I have to uh apologize.
I'm I'm not a speaker. I'm just I'm not
a public speaker. I'm so nervous right
now and yeah. Today I'm going to talk
about some of the latest social media
trends. So, so bear with me here.
I don't want you to do that.
That is a weak opening.
I understand that public speaking is one
of the greatest personal fears in the
world. In fact, it is the greatest
personal fear in the world, also known
as glossophobia.
But if you were being asked to deliver a
presentation, in this instance on social
media,
you were being asked for a reason. You
are probably a subject matter expert.
Somebody values your opinion.
I want you to be confident.
Of course, this is not an excuse to not
practice. You want to practice many
times to build that confidence, but on
the day of the speech, don't start your
speech with apologies.
That weakens it right away and and
audience members may take less value
from your presentation. Instead, why not
open with a powerful fact?
Did you know that 80% of videos on
social media are viewed without the
sound on?
So, if you're going to all of the work
of creating
a video,
but you're not including subtitles or
captions,
80% of your audience may not be getting
the context.
Today, I'm going to tell you several
social media tips which will help
elevate your business.
You see the difference? An example like
that, you're giving right away value.
This is probably something many people
hadn't heard of before, and you yourself
come across as an expert. Even if you're
internally feeling very nervous, do not
start your speech with an apology. Have
you ever been part of a corporate
meeting that starts out something like
this?
Okay, we have the annual fundraiser
that's coming up. Does anyone have any
ideas of of what we can do this year, or
what we should focus on, or maybe how we
can make tweaks to what we did last
year? Any thoughts, anyone?
These
questions that are lobbed out to the
group without any real purpose, or the
lack of structure,
first off, is not captivating. Even
though it's a meeting, it should still
draw people's interest so that they pay
attention.
But also,
what you'll often find, and this happens
a lot on Zoom meetings or virtual
meetings as well, is that when questions
are lobbed out into the ether,
either nobody speaks up,
or the same person is always the person
speaking up to talk. And that might
actually rub other people the wrong way,
and this is not the best way to run a
meeting. What I would challenge you to
do instead is think a little bit more
about what the goal should be, and why
not open that meeting with a really
provocative or challenging statement.
This year,
we're going to double the amount of
funds raised from last year.
Wow. What an ambitious goal and target
that has set the tone. Now people are
thinking, how are we going to do that?
And as the leader of the meeting, I then
get specific with the questions. Brett,
you were lead of the organizing
committee last year.
I'd like you to share with the group
what went really well and some areas
that we could perhaps improve upon.
Angela, you're new to the team.
How can we double the amounts of funds
raised based on what Brett has just
said?
By asking specific people these types of
questions and using their experience or
their lack of experience as a positive
and springboarding a question that is
contextually relevant to them, that is
going to help your meetings be more
dynamic, be more inspiring, get maximum
participation,
and you won't have the long awkward
pauses with nobody wanting to speak up.
Have you ever been at an event where
there's some element of public speaking
and there's a microphone and somebody
takes it and does one of two things.
Number one,
hello? Whoa, whoa, this thing is loud.
Or number two, hello? Can everyone hear
me? Can you Can you all Can everyone
hear me in the back?
If this is how you're starting your
speech, it's killing momentum in both
examples. Example one, that surprise
that your voice is amplified by a
microphone,
you shouldn't be surprised. That is the
pure purpose of a microphone. Your voice
is supposed to get very loud.
And in example number two, sure, you
might be ensuring that the room can hear
you, but that makes you come across less
professional.
It's not exciting. You're wasting those
first few seconds of important real
estate of capturing the audience's
attention
with just this generic housekeeping
item.
The way around this is first and
foremost to do a mic check, especially
if a mic check is offered. And if it's
not, ask the event organizer, "Hey, is
there a chance I can get on the stage
early and just get familiar with the
mic? I want to know if I'm using a
handheld or a lav mic. I want to hear my
voice being projected."
That goes a long way so that when you
can hear that, you're no longer
surprised by hearing your voice
amplified, but also if you've gone
through the process of a mic check, now
you're not having to ask the audience if
they can hear you because you can do
that test in advance and you'll know,
"Okay, I can hear my voice being
amplified. When we did the mic check
earlier, everyone had confirmed they
could hear me at the back." So now I
don't have to waste time. Instead, I can
jump right into a story. I can ask a
thought-provoking question or I can give
a powerful stat or fact. That is a much
more powerful way to start a speech
than the mic test amateur moves I
explained before. Have you ever attended
an event or a conference where a speaker
comes up and they fully use the lectern.
They have notes that are placed on the
lectern. They grip the sides and perhaps
the lectern's facing this way. They
rarely make eye contact, perhaps
periodically, but they basically stand
here at the front of the room and they
read their notes to the audience of
whatever it is that they're talking
about. And from time to time they'll
look up, but usually it's in the same
spot and their voice has this monotone
cadence and maybe the more advanced
speakers sometimes bring up their hands,
but it's almost this death grip on the
lectern.
This is not a powerful way to introduce
a speech. And right away, by starting
your speech this way,
it showcases to the audience that you
have limited abilities when it comes to
public speaking.
What I would suggest you do is the first
thing I just did. If there is a lectern,
turn it diagonally if you do need notes
of some form. Because the best speakers
don't use notes at all, but if you're
not quite there, you can have some
bullet point notes,
but have them like this. Because this
allows you to detach from the lectern
and when we detach, instantly we have
the opportunity to use more vocal
variety to capture people's attention,
but also we're free with our hands. And
we can bring them up to emphasize
certain things that we're talking about
because this creates more engagement
with the audience.
And then if need be, you can
periodically come back and take a quick
glance at your next bullet point and
then you can return to the audience.
I really want you to practice from
detaching from notes. I would love all
of you watching this video to give your
next speech without relying on any notes
because it is so much more engaging, so
much more powerful when we are able to
lock eyes with the audience, use our
body language, use our hands, use our
voice.
That makes for a more memorable speech.
And why do you want to have a more
memorable speech? So your audience
remembers your message. That thing you
were trying to teach them, it has a
better chance of landing, a better
chance of sticking with them. I hope
these examples of weak speech openings
and better alternatives of how to
improve the speech openings has been
beneficial to you. As I mentioned
earlier in this video, if you are a
professional or somebody who's looking
to take public speaking more seriously,
check out my Stan Store link and work
with me on a one-on-one basis.
If you have not yet subscribed,
why not? Subscribe to my channel. I have
so much free content which is going to
help you be a more impactful
communicator, a better public speaker,
have confident from the stage,
confidence from the stage, and it's all
free. It's all free on YouTube. And
finally, check out this video YouTube is
recommending for you right now. Thank
you for watching this one.